there are human beings who are just made
differently than the rest of us to be
able to play and function at that level
for quarterbacks it includes the ability
to throw a football
far and fast and accurately and matt
ryan one of the best at doing that over
the past 12 or 13 years here he is
talking about his future with the
atlanta falcons the only team for which
he's ever played and the fact that he
believes he's appreciated by his
organization
you know i understand i'm not going to
play forever but i also
you know have the mindset that i'm still
playing really well and and have you
know a lot of good football in front of
me but the most important thing to me is
it comes from the belief in the building
the people who are actually making
decisions uh the people who um
you know are with you day to day i think
there's been a shift uh for sure you
know during during my time in the nfl
um
you know where guys have become more
vocal about certain situations and
um
you know i think that's a good thing
from a player's standpoint uh is is you
want some of that you want your voice to
be heard
um i i feel like
you know within our organization you
know within the building that i've been
in i've been in a a really fortunate
spot where my voice has been heard uh
and i've always felt that way and always
felt appreciated but
um
you know so i can't speak for other
people's situations i just feel
fortunate that mine has been
um
you know as solid as it has been for for
the better part of 14 years
uh hey look
smart tactful but also
instructive on what other quarterbacks
are dealing with they do listen to matt
ryan they do yeah and and that's the
thing you don't have to do what the guy
says
you just give him a seat at the table
yeah let him attend the meeting don't
tell him we we're fine you go do
whatever it is you're supposed to do
we'll do what we're supposed to do and
and do your job this out that's how it
works you don't tell us
anything
we don't want to hear it no that that's
not the attitude that works but by the
way i've
i i've known about the concept of the
farmer's tan for years matt ryan's got
the farmer's sunburn did you notice that
yes
i mean at first i thought he had caught
at first i thought he had caught the
bruce aryans yeah he was going the same
thing on the color of whatever shirt
you're wearing right but you can see the
the rim there that's uh
yeah sunscreen matthew come on you're
old enough to know about that anyway and
he's white as me he's got to be careful
down there in atlanta
far more importantly this is a guy that
still has gas in the tank this is a guy
that even though they're in the process
of out with the old and in with the new
you don't throw overboard a guy who is
still among
the better
half of quarterbacks in the nfl i don't
know where he falls between 11 and and
16.
maybe he's 11. i don't know
but but he's not a guy that you say
all right we're just gonna get rid of
him and we're gonna roll the dice with a
rookie who may or may not be anything
special over the course of time no no
doubt about it right we had this talk a
lot during the draft process i mean this
day and age 2021 quarterback being 36
years old like who gives a damn that's
like the you know that's it's truly i
mean there's been like a change it's
like a 30 year a 36 year old quarterback
is a 30 year old quarterback from 15 20
years ago it really is that's where
we've gone that's how far sports science
and and the training and everything like
that has all you know done for
quarterbacks especially uh to play
longer in the nfl i mean and he's still
really good like you talked about i mean
yeah you don't give that up a guy that's
got at least three really good years
left before you're even worried about
like oh man is he in trouble physically
or anything like that
yes i just don't think you abandon ship
on that type of formula uh for a for a
we think type prospect at pick number
four we think he might be good and all
those type of things so matt ryan like
he said he's still playing at a very
high level they haven't been great
they've been an injured football team
and they can win a super bowl with matt
ryan and to me that's the number one
thing if you can answer that then you
don't really give that up you don't give
that up and that's still a real answer
for matt ryan
they had a super bowl one with matt i
know i know
it's reality yes they're up 28 to three
now look i think that the failure in
that game bears the fingerprints of many
and i've made the argument in the past
that whoever called
the past play when they were in field
goal range that resulted in the sack
that took out a field goal range right
that peyton manning
potentially
shows a finger to the sideline and and
doesn't call that play
but there's only one peyton manning
matt ryan
called the play that was that's right
sent in and and so but but but
regardless yeah he's an mvp
he had the team up 28-3 late in the
third quarter the super bowl
and i i i've been a believer that the
falcons are never going to truly recover
from that moment until they have full
and complete turnover of the roster but
that's not
that that belief that theory that
hypothesis isn't nearly
strong enough to say you get rid of a
guy who's still got gas in the tank who
has been among the better quarterbacks
in the nfl for the bulk of his career
yeah that's right you know and and and
we hired a new coach who
the offensive system fits the
quarterback that we currently have on
the roster
and you know mike like you you make a
good point there you're right i don't
know maybe they won't ever get over it
you know as an organization
i don't know if
you know i think matt ryan can get over
it that's all i'm saying i don't think
if he got back in the super bowl that's
going to affect him in any shape way or
form i at least i don't think it will um
but he's just done a lot of good things
and
you know it just shows too like i know
we showed like the we're because we're
bringing up matt ryan and some of this
stuff too about he's got an organization
that supports him and an owner that's
always like you've said at least takes
what he has to say into account not that
they're gonna go oh whatever you say
we're gonna do
but oh this is what you think my matt
okay now we're gonna go talk about hey
matt thinks this you know it doesn't
mean they do it but they've always made
him feel that way and he's the number
two pick of the draft they've supported
him with talent throughout his career
and yeah he feels comfortable they've
done a great job i mean it's a crazy we
showed rogers and matt ryan i mean what
what we got now matt ryan's got what
four first round picks he's throwing two
aaron rodgers zero right right it's he's
got hayden hurst kyle pitts
ridley julio jones he's got two top ten
picks a top 23 pick and a top 28 pick to
throw to the football throw the football
to and uh that's not fair for aaron
rodgers
you know there's still that possibility
julio jones is going to be traded after
june 1. and i feel like the way that
that all came out the monday of draft
week the falcons are hoping that someone
will make them an offer his salary is
guaranteed this year the falcons
probably would have to pay some of it
there hasn't been any real traction but
but who knows all it takes is one team
to make a phone call at the right time
for it to happen but but if julio jones
is there yeah jones ridley hearst pitts
my goodness and mike davis with those
thighs i mean he's got a chance to be
the starting running back i don't have a
you know a guy
a high-end guy right now it's going to
be a a committee approach in all
likelihood so
i
look when everyone's zero and zero it's
easy to say don't sleep on insert name
of team but it's not like anyone has the
falcons pegged
to be among
the worst i was looking at the lines
westgate has all the lines for every
week the betting lines and teams like
the texans the bengals the lions the
jaguars they're the ones who are
weak in week out more likely to be the
team that isn't favored to win i just
don't think the falcons are in that cut
of teams this year i know even with a
new gm and a new head coach no i don't
either i just think you know there's
there's too many talented guys on the
roster
right and now yeah you got a head co a
head coach who's coming over is going to
bring a pretty tried and proven system
from tennessee that i think the
personnel fits so i'd be shocked on the
offensive side of the ball if that
doesn't work and then hey there's
there's some talent the defense is going
to be a different a whole different look
that's what i'm that's where i think a
lot of this could fall on too i don't
question this falcon's offense what they
can do i expect points and and you know
consistency and all those things but
they are leaving the dan quinn scheme
and now going to dean pease which is a
little more of that ravens new england
multiple defenses bigger up front not as
small and fast and those type of things
so i that's another big piece of the
puzzle just how they can kind of bring
it all together as a team and did they
get the right personnel in there to make
that change you know in the system to to
make it work uh for for their defense
and it's critical that a team like the
falcons take full advantage of the off
season program so they can teach those
players
in the defense right you're not i don't
think you're gonna hear about mandatory
mini camp being scrapped for the atlanta
falcons issue
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports